now when respawn a couple weeks ago
released their statistics were titanfall
- considering how many like the how many
people used certain weapon how many
Titans were used I noticed that the top
three Titans were tonne legion and ion
now tones probably been covered by a
multitude of people questioning why
she's overpowered and why we should
nerve her yada yada yada but I never
seen anything on Legion and since she or
is it he or she we're gonna go with she
she's the second most used Titan there's
got to be something with her that's
super good now I'm not saying that we
should nerve her but I'm just saying
there's gonna be a lot of legions you
got to know how to counter them you got
on how to defeat them so I came up with
a way to defeat Legion with every Titan
and as a pilot I'm titanfall to now
we're gonna start easy with the pilot
the pilot loadout you can have is from
the Titan time Titan killer video so
shout out to them it is a pilot loadout
consists of an amped wall with a
devotion or an mg L or Archer as your
anti-titan weapon the amped wall will
double your practically double your
damage instance the devotion is one of
the fastest guns in the game you can
bring it legion from five bars of health
to half of the last bar of health the mg
l and the archer just make it even worse
so you could basically doom him as long
as you're not getting shot though now
for Titans we're gonna be talking about
ion ion is probably the best counter
towards the Legion because all ion has
to do is just peak pop his deflect
shield take all of his bullets and shoot
it right back at him you can just
basically keep doing this every other
time and he's gonna get super aggravated
or and leave or he's gonna start
charging you and that's where you pop
your tripwire and any of the other
abilities you have equipped with you
the next one we're gonna be talking
about is scorch and scorches the same as
ayan except clearly he can't reflect
them he just burns the bullets which is
although it's not as great it's still
good but what you can do is you can
definitely pick him off from a distance
with your grenade launcher if you have
good enough aim and if he starts
charging you or getting too close to
your liking then you can start trapping
him using the incendiary traps and then
throw down the the wild fire and you can
easily take down his health in a matter
of seconds and then the next one is
North Star North Star is was the one
that had that got me the most trouble
basically I couldn't figure out a decent
knife way all I can think of is just as
North Star stay as far away from Legion
as you can if he starts running up on
you try to use your tether trap and bait
him or something because no I'm not
really that great with North Star and
it's kind of hard to go up against the
Legion when your North Star it's a very
troubling time and the next one would be
Ronan though this one's a little bit
different but still kind of the same
it's hard because Ronan's got no health
and he has an up-close and quarters kit
unlike North Star where she has a sniper
Ronan's got a shotgun he has to rush up
on him so what you can do is you can
couple the arc wave I I forgot one and
the I forgot the abilities name but
allows you to carry two arc waves you
can arc wave shoot a whole clip of your
letter ball onto him reload shoot your
arc wave shoot a couple or shoot your
whole clip of the lead wall into them
and then if you get in trouble start
phase shifting away or start sword
blocking you can work that up to get
your sword core or if you have a
teammate you can double-team him whether
that's a pilot or a Titan and then you
can easily kill Legion and get his
health down now the next Titan would be
tone essence tone is used a lot she has
plenty of strengths and weaknesses all
you have to do is just play tone like
normal stay at a medium range pick them
off from a distance with your gun use
the tracking Rockets when you're fully
locked on or use the sonar pulse if they
try to run away
and then get up and close and use that
salvo core now if you're playing as a
legion and you're facing another legion
this could get interesting
use the long-range firing mode and then
pick him off from a distance because you
always want to get as far away as you
can from the legion and if you're out in
the open and you happen to be and he
caught you pop your gun shield it's kind
of hard because I'm not exactly the
greatest with Legion or North Star
that's why some of these are very basic
in terms of like tone and ion and Ronan
where I'm a lot better with them instead
of those two so I'm sorry if those
didn't have much like variety or
definition to it that's my apologies but
anyway that's going to be the end of the
video that's basically how to defeat
Legion with every Titan and pilot so I
hope you all did enjoy subscribe if you
did
there'll be plenty more titanfall videos
and the for honor beta will be coming
soon so I'm definitely gonna be playing
a bit of that like the video if you did
enjoy though and then comment your
opinion on what you thought of it or if
you have any other ideas to taking down
on Legion please comment those as well
helps always appreciated and peace out